>>> PRESIDENT BIDEN WARNED
RUSSIAN OLIGARCH, HIS
MINISTRATION PLANS TO SEIZE
THEIR ILL-GOTTEN GAINS.
NOW SEIZING THE YACHTS.
FRIDAY TITALIAN AUTHORITIES SEIE
THE YACHT OF SA, OWNED BY ANDRE
MELNICHENKO, HE OWNED A
FERTILIZER.
THIS FOLLOWED THE IMPOUNDING OF
LADY M OWNED BY ALEXI MORDASHOV.
AND LENA BELONGING TO GENNADY
TIMCHENKO.
THE FRENCH OFFICIALS SEIZED THE
AMORE ZERO CLAIMING IT'S OWNED
BY IGOR SECHIN OWNED BY THE
COMPANY ROSNEFT.
PREVENTING IT FROM.
HAPPENING AFTER IT LEFT PORT THE
SUPERNOVA OWNED BY THE MOGUL
TURNED OFF AUTOMATIC TRACKING
SYSTEMS AGAINST THE LAW FOR A
SHIP OF ITS SIZE.
AFTER BRITAIN SANCTIONED ROMAN
ABRAMOVICH, THE BILLIONAIRE
SELLING HIS STAKE IN THE
FOOTBALL CLUB CHELSEA, HIS
SUPERYACHTS BEGAN MOVING WITHOUT
EXTR
EXTRADITION AGREEMENTS.
HIS SHIP, ECLIPSE, ITS OWN
MISSILE DEFENSE SYSTEM, A
SUBMARINE AS ONE.
ESTIMATED VALUE OF $1 BILLION.
AND THE SECRET OTHER THAN OF A
459-FOOT $700 MILLION SUPERYACHT
CURRENTLY ANCHORED IN A TOWN OF
TUSCANY MAY BE OWNED BY VLADIMIR
PUTIN HIMSELF.
AND IT BOASTS TWO HELICOPTER
DECKS, A SWIMMING POOL THAT
CONVERTS TO A DANCE FLOOR AND
GOLD-PLATED FIXTURES.
THE SHIP'S CAPITAL SAID THAT
PUTIN DID NOT OWN THE YACHT TO
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
AND SAYING THAT THE MYSTERY
OWNER WAS NOT ON THE SANCTIONS
LIST BUT PREVENTED HIM FROM
REVEALING MORE.
PUTIN OWNS VERY LITTLE IN HIS
OWN NAME.
JOINING ME IS ALEX FINDLAY, A
FORMER CIA OFFICER IN BARCELONA.
HE'S BEEN MAINTAINING A YACHT
WATCH ON TWITTER AND EXTENDING
IT AS PART OF RESEARCH FOR A
FOURTH COMING NOVEL.
ALEX, THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE,
I REMEMBER A STORY IN "THE NEW
YORK TIMES" THAT TALKED ABOUT
JUST HOW DIFFICULT IT IS TO
FIGURE OUT THE OWNERSHIP OF REAL
ESTATE IN MIDTOWN MANHATTAN
BECAUSE IN PART OF OLIGARCHS
GOING TO GREAT LENGTHS TO HIDE
THEIR IDENTITY.
THIS IS JUST LIKE THAT, RIGHT,
IT'S TOUGH TO FIGURE OUT WHO
OWNS THEM?
>> YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT.
MOST OF THESE SHIPS ARE ACTUALLY
OWNED BY FRONT COMPANIES AND
THEY HAVE PROPERTY MANAGERS WHO
SORT OF RUN THEM.
MOST OF THEM ARE FLAGGED IN
PLACES LIKE YOU NOTED THE
MARSHALL ISLANDS, CAYMAN
ISLANDS, ISLE OF WIGHT, AND IT'S
DIFFICULT TO UNTANGLE WHO THE
BENEFICIAL OWNER IT IS.
THERE'S SHELL COMPANY AFTER
SHELL COMPANY.
TRYING TO FOLLOW THAT BACK AND
FIGURE OUT WHO THE OWNER IS VERY
DIFFICULT AND DONE THAT WAY ON
PURPOSE.
>> WHAT ARE YOU NOTING AS YOU'RE
TRACKING THEM?
IS THERE ANY CONCERTED EFFORT
THAT COMES TO LIGHT OR ARE THEY
ALL GOING IN SEPARATE
DIRECTIONS?
WHAT ARE THE PATTERNS?
>> SO FAR, WE'VE SEEN A NUMBER
OF THEM THAT HAVE LEFT EUROPE.
THEY SEEM TO BE HEADING SOUTH.
THERE'S QUESTIONS IF THEY WOULD
TRY TO GO THROUGH TO THE BLACK
SEA, BUT WITH TURKEY, IT'S NOT
CLEAR IF THAT WOULD BE A GOOD
MOVE FOR THEM.
SO SOME SEEM TO BE MOVING
THROUGH THE SUEZ CANAL AND
INDIAN OCEAN, WE'VE SEEN A
NUMBER OF THEM CLUSTER AROUND
THE SEYCHELLES AND MALDIVES.
THERE ARE FEW PLACES THAT CAN
SERVICE AND MAINTAIN THESE
YACHTS.
YOU WERE RUNNING STATISTICS
ABOUT THESE.
THESE ARE ENORMOUS, VERY
SOPHISTICATED MACHINES.
THEY'RE WORTH A LOT OF MONEY.
THEY'RE HIGHLY TECHNOLOGY HEAVY.
THEY HAVE, LIKE YOU SAID,
MISSILE DEFENSE SYSTEMS AND THE
REST.
AND HIGH-TECH RADAR.
SO, EVEN IF IN THE END THERE ARE
SOME RUMORS THAT ALL OF THESE
BOATS ARE TRYING TO MAKE THEIR
WAY TO WHERE RUSSIAN HAS ITS
PACIFIC COMMAND, THERE ARE STILL
QUESTIONS ONCE THEY'RE THERE,
CAN THEY BE MAINTAINED?
BECAUSE THAT KNOWLEDGE, THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE IS ALL HERE IN
EUROPE AND THE UNITED STATES.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT PUTIN OWNS
THE YACHT THAT I REFERENCED THAT
RIGHT NOW IS DOCKED IN TUSCANY?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I'M WATCHING THAT ONE AS CLOSELY
AS EVERYBODY ELSE.
>> WHEN THE OLIGARCHS BOARD
THEIR YACHTS, I'VE BEEN
ARRESTING AND LEARNING THAT IT
SEEMS LIKE THEY SHIFT FROM A
CREW THAT MAY BE MULTINATIONAL
TO, ALL OF A SUDDEN, AN
ALL-RUSSIAN CREW.
CAN YOU SPEAK TO THAT?
>> YEAH.
WE HAVE HEARD SOME CASES WHERE
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS.
AN INTERNATIONAL CREW WILL MOVE
THE YACHT FROM ONE PLACE TO
ANOTHER.
BUT ONCE CERTAIN GUESTS COME ON
BOARD, ONE CREW IS DISMISSED.
AND AN ALL-RUSSIAN CREW WILL
COME ON.
AND AS YOU REFERENCED BEFORE,
ANYBODY WORKING ON THESE BOATS,
THEY HAVE NDAs, YOU KNOW, IT'S
ALL VERY HUSH-HUSH.
>> WHAT FLAGS DO THEY FLY UNDER?
OR IS IT A VARIETY OF THEM?
>> YOU MENTIONED THE MARSHALL
ISLANDS BEFORE, THE CAYMAN
ISLANDS, SOME MALTA, THE ISLE OF
MANN, ANY SORT OF OFFSHORE TECH
HAVEN THAT YOU CAN IMAGINE.
>> AND FINALLY, WHERE ARE THEY
SAFEST?
SO, IF YOU COULD SORT OF SWITCH
HATS AND YOU WERE TRYING TO
PLACE THEM IN A LOCATION WHERE
THEY WOULDN'T BE SEIZED, WHERE
WOULD THAT BE?
WHERE DO YOU THINK THEY'D MOST
WANT TO GET TO?
>> WELL, LIKE I SAID, OUTSIDE OF
THE SANCTIONED AREAS, ANYWHERE
OUTSIDE OF THE EU OR UK OR THE
U.S.
AND SOME OF THEM ARE NOT
SANCTIONED BY ALL THREE OF
THOSE.
YOU MENTIONED ABRAMOVICH'S
YACHT.
HE'S ONLY SANCTIONED AT THIS
POINT BY THE UK.
EVEN IF HE'S IN EU WATERS, I
DON'T THINK ANYBODY IS GOING TO
DO ANYTHING.
ONCE THEY REACH THE INDIAN
OCEAN, THAT'S IT.
UNLESS THESE GOVERNMENTS CAN
GET, YOU KNOW, COORDINATION.
AND HELP FROM OTHER GOVERNMENTS
WHO WANT TO HELP BUT WE'RE NOT
SEEING ANY INDICATION OF THAT SO
FAR.
WE'VE EVEN SEEN SOME INDICATIONS
THAT SOME ARE READY TO WORK WITH
THE RUSSIANS.
AND IT MEANS MORE MONEY FOR
THEM.
THE UAE IS HAPPY TO HAVE THE
RUSSIANS COME AND MAKE THE UAE
THEIR